So one of the more powerful techniques that psychologists have at their
disposal for understanding where a personality comes from is twin adoption
studies. Now, twin adoption studies are so important because they really
simulate these naturally occurring experiments as it were. So the twin part is
really shorthand for how genetically related people are. So, for instance
identical twins are 100% genetically related, fraternal twins, siblings and
parents and off springs are 50% genetically related. Cousins then for instance
are about 12% genetically related on average. The adoption part is important
because it varies the environment. So whether people are raised in the same
family and household are in different families and households. So we can't
randomly assign people to these conditions, so we have to use what nature gives
us and that's the Twin Adoption Study. So the best way to study the affects of
genes in environment or nature and nurture on personality is to study different
kinds of relatives brought up in different kinds of environments. So now let's
go to Lauren for a question.